if you've ever traveled to a foreign
country you may have noticed directional
signs or menu items where the English
translation isn't quite right in China
these linguistic misfires while amusing
to some have become something of a sore
spot for the government which wants to
present a more sophisticated image to
the rest of the world Ben Tracy shows us
how China is trying to tackle the
problem how often do you see a bad
translation every 20 minutes
Laura Jiao has been a tour guide in
Beijing for 10 years so she's seen
plenty of these signs where something
definitely got lost in translation it's
probably because we don't really use
English there are helpful reminders to
please wait outside a noodle and always
remember to enjoy the fresh air after
you finish civilized urinating why do
you think the translations were so bad
to be honest I think it's because lots
of people are lazy
yes they directly put it online and
translate it and the designer may not
really know English at all
I assume the shoes in there are not
actually old there are new shoes
traditional style so that's how
traditional Beijing shoes becomes old
Beijing shoes yes and also how a warning
not to step on the growing grass can
become I like your smile
but unlike you put your shoes on my face
most of us find this pretty funny but
the Chinese government finds it pretty
embarrassing so they have now issued
this 10-part guide which has hundreds of
official translations how to write
everything from sunbathing to ski resort
to closing time and under construction
so under the new guidelines the ones
widely used execution in progress will
become under construction the highly
offensive deformed men's toilet sign
will now read accessible toilet china
first tried to rid itself of
embarrassing Chinglish before the 2008
olympics
that's when racist Park near the Olympic
Stadium officially became Chinese ethnic
culture Park grandma hand bamboo shoes
that's probably not something I would
order but a harder problem to solve
maybe all of those menu items that sound
less than appetizing this dish is called
spicy beauty shoes what exactly is that
spicy because the flavor is spicy and
it's supposed to make you beautiful and
it's a pig a pig's foot it makes you
beautiful supposed to after the new
guidelines take effect in December
Laura expects most Chinglish signs will
be tossed into the poisonous an evil
rubbish Chinese people we are good at
following rules so whenever the
government really give you a list are
saying what it should be then everything
become easier sadly it may no longer be
easy to find the exotic romance zone for
CBS this morning Saturday Ben Tracy
Beijing you know I'll just say I don't
know that we're doing a great job of
translating our English into Chinese
characters respect to the Chinese
government for taking this bull by the
pointy I'm gonna miss some of these
signs though yes some of the signs are
absolutely priceless poisonous and evil
rubbish love that